welcome back to CBS morning's We Begin
this hour with a powerful story about
defying expectations for our series
pushing the limits we will follow a
father and son's journey to some of the
toughest Triathlon courses in the world
Jeff and Johnny agar aren't your typical
Iron Man athletes but with more than 200
races under their belts they have got
the same grit and determination as all
of the other competitors they talked
with us about overcoming the odds and
redefining what it means to be a
champion
[Music]
well Before Sunrise Jeff agar is already
20 miles into his day at 59 years old he
is training for another Triathlon it is
a goal fueled by his greatest motivation
who's on his own ride up the stairs
this is Jeff's 28 year old son Johnny oh
you're a good little boy when he was
just three weeks old Johnny was
diagnosed with cerebral palsy
there you go that a boy it is a muscle
disorder that makes it challenging for
Johnny to walk and talk
[Music]
there you go Jeff and his wife Becky
were devastated it took a couple seconds
to figure out this is the totally
different world for us this is not going
to be the typical type of thing I
remember asking him one day I said you
know what if he can't play catch with
you you know what what does that mean to
you and he that you know I just love him
it doesn't matter what he can and can't
do you know it was at that point I
thought gosh I got the right guy
ah the right guy mom's cooking when we
get home who pushes through countless
long runs
early morning swims in Michigan's frigid
Lakes
and bike rides four hours or more around
the neighborhood I believe
triathlons an individual sport that Jeff
is taking on for two people totaling 400
pounds with their equipment
when he swims he pulls John
when he bikes he hauls him good morning
thank you for being out here and when he
runs he pushes him I mean I'm not a fan
of swimming biking or running so which
is perfect for triathlon so this
probably wouldn't be in the top hundred
things I would select to do I'm not
doing it because I love it it wasn't
like a dream of mine this is Johnny's
dream I'm just giving him the legs and
the power to do it are you trying to
prove something to Johnny that's a
really good question I think we're
trying to show him that you just can't
let obstacles stand your way he's on the
inside now he's not one of these people
externally thinking what's it like he's
he's an athlete he's on the inside of
this game solid bike right then together
the agars have competed more than 200
races across nine states over the past
14 years I look at other athletes I
think to myself you know if I see
themselves
pushing themselves you know
um what can't I do how do you feel about
what your dad does for you because
really it's all for you yeah I think you
know for me it's a tremendous blessing
with me you know
I'm able to express my desires through
him and he understands that you know I
saw Dad pushing himself to get me across
the line that I said to myself this is
ridiculous I I'm capable of doing more
[Applause]
so two months ago they went after a goal
they've attempted five times before
let's go down let's go finishing a full
Ironman race that is the ultimate
endurance event it happened in Maryland
where the Father and Son Duo had to
complete the 2.4 mile swim
112 mile bike ride
and 26.2 mile run that's 140 miles in
under 17 hours and for the very first
time they did it with just five minutes
to spare
and look who crossed the finish line for
the team
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
my way of telling Dad okay I'm not just
gonna say thank you anymore I'm going to
actually put my words into action you
know I I get emotional not because I
pity you
I get emotional because it just gives me
a feeling of inspiration to listen to
you oh thank you thank you you know to
be able to inspire someone else give my
challenges purpose I think it gives my
challenges purpose well that's powerful
home stretch
and doing good Johnny is the heart
Jeff is his motor if I were married to
him
I would be over the moon in love with
him watching him do what he does for my
son you nailed it yeah
even though he got him the 140 miles
he'll always be hiding behind Johnny he
doesn't want to be announced as an Iron
Man it's Johnny's moment
and it's the most beautiful thing to me
nobody helps you and Johnny get across
the Finish Line okay right yeah you
don't get any extra time you get no
extra accommodations that's the tough
part of it but the beauty of it is if
you finish when they say you're an Iron
Man you are an Iron Man you are the same
thing as everybody else what made you
emotional there this the fact that he
would see it as he'd rather not succeed
than be treated like he's different
okay just relax breathe
what's next team agar is doubling down
they want to secure a spot at the Iron
Man World Championship that's happening
next year in Kona Hawaii it's considered
the most brutal one-day endurance event
on the planet how long does it take you
get 17 hours
yeah and we would probably use every
minute of it ever for sure
[Music]
now they competed in the world
championship back in 2016 but they
failed to finish the bike portion in the
time allowed so they were eliminated
so sometimes you win sometimes you learn
what a Priceless lesson embraced by his
teammate
and hero it's not about the matter for
me it's not about the fame it's about
doing it as a team is there a better man
than your dad I've yet to find one for
him
Father and Son their bond as strong as
ire
tempered by love
that is good
that is good I mean what else can you
say that is good I need a blanket and a
pillow you just want to go to bed and
just think about what you just saw
that's amazing David that team agar the
way he said that sometimes you win
sometimes you lose and sometimes you
learn you learn oh you also said it
gives my challenges purpose you guys
this means the perspective he wakes up
at like four in the morning to go bike
and run and swim and he doesn't even
enjoy that yeah that's it I thought that
was interesting because his boy has a
dream yeah and that's why he does what I
just I'm telling you it gets me every
time I cried watching the edit I cried
doing an interview yeah just hope that
every child describes their parents like
that yeah yes I thought that too you
found a better man he said I haven't
found it you're not the final one you
know what else fascinates me that
despite doing all that they're now ready
to take on something you hear something
that's more brutal and more challenging
they go yeah let's go do that I'm
surprised I thought that would be the
end of the story I didn't think that
they would want to do that again they
want to go back to the world
championship one more time one more time
they got to be invited so they're hoping
they get a slot oh they're going to be
invited where do we send your piece to
they're going to be all right they're
going to be invited thank you David
thank you agar family thank you very
much